this let's jump to this story from CNN
the big news today was Donald Trump
pleading not guilty in a Georgia
elections election subversion case and
seeking to sever his case from
co-defendants who want a speedy trial
that's it Donald Trump uh sent in a
signed document saying that he was
waiving his right to appear he would be
pleading not guilty and we currently
await the uh the next steps which
they're trying uh funny William uh
Willis wants the trial to be March 4th
but that likely will not happen because
what we're hearing they've got uh 12
million documents released in Discovery
and there's absolutely no way a defense
could prepare in that short amount of
time so it's creating an interesting
predicament but the big news outside of
Trump's not guilty plea is the D.A
Bonnie Williams uh Willis lying to the
court
or it appears to the court in order to
justify withholding evidence we have two
tweets one from Adam classfeld saying
D.A Willis wants to advise all the
defendants in the Trump racketeering
case that Decisions by Ken chaseborough
and Sydney Powell to invoke Speedy Trail
rights come with certain consequences
Mike certavich responded this isn't even
true it's it's not how the law works but
this really is a mask off moment Fulton
County D.A threatens to violate the
rights of the defendants because she's
not prepared for a trial she actually
said that if you request your
constitutional right for a speedy trial
you can't argue they're entitled to
Discovery they can't argue that they're
entitled to notice of the state's
similar transaction evidence 10 days in
advance they are precluded from calling
any Witnesses whose statements were not
provided to the state 10 days in advance
and the defendants can can now complain
cannot now complain they have received
less than seven days notice
I'm seeing a ton of legal uh analysts
saying like wow she's outright lying and
if you actually look at the the cases
she's citing for precedent none of them
say what she's saying she's trying to
pull a fast one yes because they're evil
they're corrupt and at some point people
need to realize this is not law this is
not
a Judicial System
this is the exercise of political power
and the question that's being posed by
this judge in the proud voice case and
by the D.A in Georgia is can we get away
with it that's the question
and I wonder a lot of people said the
Supreme Court will intervene I don't
think the Supreme Court is going to
intervene as it pertains to the proud
boys
no no I don't I don't I I they might
intervene as it pertains to Trump but
we'll see but already we can see that
Democrats are willing to lie in court I
mean it's not surprising we saw Kyle
Rittenhouse they fabricated evidence
that's the craziest thing to try and
convict that kid here we are
I mean I don't think they have much of
anything and and the way the that I was
reading the indictments was basically
anytime Donald Trump complained about
something that was part of the
conspiracy so they they quite literally
were listing all of his tweets which he
has a lot and every single tweet is part
of the greater conspiracy at hand
um and and to me it makes me wonder like
does the president have the right
for freedom of speech does the president
have the right to complain all right
because I we we have all these different
situations in the past where someone is
contesting an election
and we have a process in place but
that's what we did he complained they
did a recount they went through the
process so are you now penalizing him
for complaining because that's what it
sounds like
um that's the case yeah
you go to prison for it now and a judge
will then Advocate others do the same
thing you did right so that's why the
Supreme Court I think will step in
because if it sets a precedent that you
can't complain about an election that
you disagree with and you can't bring
claims about an election that you
disagree with that would undermine the
Constitution the inherent aspect of the
U.S Constitution this allows us for a
redress of of our you know of our but
I'm I'm disagreement I keep hearing from
people saying you know we've gotten
super chats where they're like Tim stop
acting like the Supreme Court's not
going to shut this down and I'm like
just like they they uh responded to the
Texas V Pennsylvania lawsuit
when Texas said that these other states
are engaging in election practices in
violation of the Constitution thus
subverting a process we're involved in
the Supreme Court said no and it's the
craziest thing ever because I feel like
this it was Thomas and Alito said we
have to take this but the wrestling were
like nah we want you know what the real
the reality is they're cowards and they
just wanted the election to be over with
you know I was talking to Will
Chamberlain a long time ago about it and
he said
I think I said it on the show The issue
is that if they step into this lawsuit
it will expose them as having no
enforcement power and so the Supreme
Court really has to do light things when
they issue rulings it has to be done
such a way that it can reasonably be
accomplished but if they try and do
something more drastic like send back
five or six states electoral vote counts
to be re litigated thus changing the
results of the election
then there's questions as to whether or
not they can enforce any of these things
when people resist their their rulings
yeah if they ruled on this Trump case
and they were like no this is not
constitutional you had a right to
question the elections all the things he
did was constitutionally legal and then
the Biden Administration continues to go
forward with it after Supreme Court
declaration that would be just like
tearing the threads of society apart and
that's and that's what the Supreme
Court's worried about that if they do
issue a ruling and the Democrats don't
care and keep doing whatever they want
look at this way if the Supreme Court
intervenes and says this truck these
charges against Trump are
unconstitutional they violate the
supremacy clause blah blah blah and then
the Democrats say so what
Supreme Court no longer exists at that
point and they probably want that it's
like nine people nine nine people in the
Supreme Court right now nine people they
buy their bodyguards
so it's like nine people with some some
protection against the entire federal
government the Ft the FTA the uh the CIA
the NSA the FBI and then against nine
dudes sitting and of course some of them
are women but nine people sitting on the
Supreme Court like they don't have power
it's nine old people or like nine judges
I mean but that's true of our whole
system right like you have as much power
as you can they have as much power as we
consent to give them and that was the
idea of having these three balances
these branches that bounce each other
out that's that's technically correct
they have as much power as police are
willing to enforce against so if the
Supreme Court says something like you
can no longer uh bar people from having
guns
that's an interesting question in New
York they ruled that uh they said
president was set that women are allowed
to be topless because it is a violation
of the Civil Rights Act and
constitutional rights for men to be
allowed not to wear a shirt but women
being forced to wear a shirt
you still have cops arrest women
regularly for going topless because
those cops don't care what is legal they
care about their morals and so there's
apparently some like morbidly obese old
woman who's in her 50s who intentionally
goes around with just like massive old
saggy boobs and the police will be like
ma'am you need to put a shirt on and go
no I don't and they'll save them we're
going to arrest you and she goes do it
she immediately files a lawsuit and they
instantly settle every single time
because it is illegal so why is that
these cops are willing to enforce on
enforce them this not a law or that's
not legally enforceable but they'll do
it anyway
so the issue then become the Supreme
Court comes in and says you have to
release Trump and they go no
Supreme Court's gonna bang the gavel
again well we order you to release Trump
no thank you and then what what's
supposed to happen like a rogue
executive branch is like no we're not
gonna then does is that when the FBI
turns on the executive branch no like
there are the executive branch who
guards the Supreme Court what's the the
military structure that protects the
Supreme Court from a crazy executive
Marshals I guess U.S Marshals
but I'm not sure that they're dedicated
explicitly to just the Supreme Court not
sure there's this Supreme Court
um I think they're the Supreme Court
police they might be getting their total
wrong because I remember when uh after
Roe v Wade came out one of the big
challenges was the fact that people you
know their homes a lot of their homes
had been docks and so they were needing
to sort of redouble the support that
their security had and remember Congress
specifically passing something to make
sure that the protection was extended to
their families because it had become so
critical because these writers just
stayed outside their house I guess
they're not writers protesters but yeah
the the Marshals are the enforcement arm
of the U.S federal courts that's cool
that's uh Vivek wants to move a lot of
the FBI over to the U.S Marshals
it sounds almost innocuous but that's a
big difference serving the executive
branch or serving the judicial branch I
didn't used to think it was a big
difference I thought it was all serving
the American government and I would like
it to maintain that and continue to be
that
I agree and I think that that makes
sense as far as uh Will Chamberlain was
saying that's why it has to be light
things it can't be something Grand
because who's going to enforce it you
know so you're talking about protecting
but protecting themselves but how do you
enforce something like that that when
you're talking about actually possibly
imprisoning someone uh you know for
something that great
and you know I don't think they have
much teeth they don't have any real way
of enforcing it so they like you said
kind of cowards and they died from it I
think that you combine what's going on
with Trump and the j6ers and uh and like
Joe Biggs and they are perhaps
intentionally creating a recipe for
disaster
they they want
an explosion I I wonder if the mentality
of these people is that either we win or
everyone loses
but why
I don't know uh there's a really funny
quote from Michael malice Pizza gate
aged better than russiagate
I'm not saying that's true I'm saying
these people fear criminal prosecution
for a variety of crimes like Joe Biden
engaging in the barisma Scandal the
things they accused Trump of turned out
to be lies in fact Ukraine gate was the
best because it turned out that Trump
was actually the good guy trying to weed
out the corruption and then they go and
protect Joe Biden instead so there are
criminals actively using law enforcement
against the just American people who are
trying to put a stop to their corruption
and it's unsurprising people who want to
play by the rules are being beaten down
by those who are cheating it's the exact
same scenario when you end up with a
Criminal with a gun breaking into a
liquor store and killing the clerk who
doesn't have a gun the law says you
can't have a gun so the criminals don't
care and do whatever they want and the
innocent civilians aren't allowed to
protect themselves and Beca and get
victimized be up because of it and now
you have in the political system
Republicans being like well we gotta go
slow and play by the rules and Democrats
are like let's just cheat
do whatever we want lock them all up and
then if we lose well if we just burn it
all the ground
but I think this is
this is a much bigger thing talking
about how big the federal government has
become and you talked about the
establishment you know the the only time
the the mainstream media ever said that
Trump was presidential was when he
bombed Syria yeah they were very happy
about that they're very happy about that
um I think back to Obama one of the
reasons why people were disappointed by
Obama because Obama gave all these lofty
goals like these really big things that
he was going to do for the American
people and what did he do he went in and
played ball and did like what everybody
else does and guess what they loved him
for it but as soon as you start to
reject those things you start to not
play ball you start to reject the
establishment you start to reject War
you start to mess up with uh other
Industries
um calling out corruption nobody likes
that and I think this is this is the
counter effect to it so while some
people think it's the I don't like his
Mean Tweets really it's about him
challenging
the status quo
um well I don't think he's perfect but
there's there's a certain element that
pisses pisses people off and uh within
the federal government uh that he's
doing and I think this is part of the
punishment for doing so you guys are
playing civilization it's a game of
great game Tim you know it and it's as
if the U.S military-industrial complex
funnily enough was going for a military
Victory they're attempting to conquer
and control Earth with police state they
have military bases all over they want
order through military force then Trump
comes in he's like no I want to change
our Victory condition let's do something
cultural or something I don't even know
what his victory condition was but it
was a military space space you want a
technology Victory so but they're like
dude we have all these troops we are
paying for them we cannot stop just stop
we can't disband our entire four we've
spent decades building this Army it's in
position and Trump's like I'm not doing
it no dude we cannot have this guy run
the country because he's screwing up our
military Victory I don't I don't think
it's I mean that's that's one way to put
it but the reality is Trump's
right now Trump is saying one yes bring
our troops home secure our borders bring
back manufacturing and you have people
who have built their whole lives around
the liberal economic order that is
maintain World Police
it's not that you know they want a
military Victory but I get your point
it's more so that Trump is saying how do
we make America better how do we improve
the lives of our citizens whereas these
people are like how do we control the
world citizens be damned
yeah and then that's why I feel like
when you asked earlier why would they
why would they do this I think it's
because well there's probably different
people would do it for different reasons
some people probably because he's called
Rosie O'Donnell a fat pig and they're
like I I will do anything to not have
that in my life you know these really
but some people are afraid like he's
going to screw up the victory condition
this thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time